هل هذا مكان جيد جدًا
لقصر الذاكرة الخاص بك ، نعم ، هذا
هو أصدقاء الذاكرة المثاليين فقط
لأنه لدينا الكثير من الأشياء المختلفة
المثيرة للاهتمام بحيث يمكنك
إرفاق أشياء بها ، لذلك دعونا نفعل
الرؤساء ،
حسنًا ، نوعًا ما في الوسط  نعم ،
وما نحتاج إلى فعله قبل أن نبدأ في
الحفظ هو نوع من اختيار
مسارنا أو نوع من
الأشياء التي سنرسي عليها الصور ،
لذلك عندما أسير في قصور الذاكرة هذه ،
لدي أشياء تسمى
نقاط الربط أو المواقع و  هذا هو المكان الذي تتخيل فيه
بالفعل
صورة الشيء الذي
تحفظه على تلك يمكن أن تكون قطع أثاث من
زوايا الغرف مهما كنا هنا في
هذا الموقع الأول
وسنبدأ بالرئيس الخامس والعشرين ،
هل تعرف من هو  في أي حال من
الأحوال ،
ربما تفكر كينلي ماكينلي في جبل
ماكينلي الذي يعد أعلى قمة
في الولايات المتحدة ، وأنا أقول
ذلك فقط لأن هذا
أمر سهل تخيله أنه مجرد جبل ضخم
في ألاسكا ، أليس كذلك؟  حسنًا ،
ما أريدك أن تتخيله في هذا الباب
هو ويمكننا فعل ذلك بعدة طرق ،
ربما نفتح الأبواب وهناك
هذا المشهد الجميل
لأطول قمة في أمريكا الشمالية
جبل
ماكينلي وربما نفتح هذا الباب ونحن حقًا
تريد أن تضيف الكثير من الألوان إليها ،
فإن انفجار هواء ألاسكا الشتوي البارد
يجعلك تشعر بالبرودة ويتطاير الثلج ،
ويمكنك فقط أن تتخيل أنك
محاط بالثلج والبرد ، حسنًا ،
لذلك ننتقل إلى
الموقع التالي وهو  كن تيدي روزفلت ،
لذلك عندما أفكر في تيدي روزفلت ،
أفكر في دمية دب ،
فهذا سريع وسهل ، وما سنصوره
هو دمية دب كبير محبوب يجلس على
هذه
الطاولة الريفية ، آه
، حسنًا ، ونحن ننتقل إلى الكرة الأرضية  هنا
الكرة الأرضية حاضرة لهذه
الصورة ، طوافة عملاقة تطفو على
محيطات العالم
، طوفًا يتناغم مع القافية بجانب
ساعة الجد هذه لويلسون ، لماذا
خطر ببالني كرة تنس براقة ويلسون ،
لذا تخيل نفسك تحطمني  من
خلال وجه الساعة
هذا أخيرًا في هذه الغرفة ، الأريكة للهيكل
بدلاً من الأريكة المريحة ، تخيل أن
تلك الأريكة
قاسية جدًا لتؤذيك